[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
herzlich Willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland und zum dritten Fall unserer
Miniserie über den Mord an Nicole Brown
Simpson und natürlich über den
Mordprozess gegen OJ Simpson mein Name
ist Toni Heyer und ich bin Mirko Kasimir
wenn ihr die ersten beiden Folgen noch
nicht gehört habt dann würden wir euch
unbedingt empfehlen bei Folge 1 zu
beginnen wir geben euch aber gleich noch
eine kurze Zusammenfassung Toni in der
Nacht vom 12 zum 13 Juni 1994 werden die
35-Jährige Nicole Brown Simpson und der
25-Jährige Ronald Goldman ein Freund von
Nicole von Nicoles Haus in Los Angeles
mit Messerstichen ermordet der Verdacht
fällt bald auf ihren Ex-Mann OJ Simpson
einen früheren football star der zu
diesem Zeitpunkt Schauspiel er
Werbeikone und Vollzeit zu Liberty ist
am Tatort werden Blutspuren und ein
Handschuh gefunden ein Teil der
Blutspuren kann oJ Simpsons werden und
auf dessen Grundstück wird der fehlende
Handschuh entdeckt
auf diesem Handschuh finden Sie
Blutspuren von OJ Simpson und von beiden
Opfern und eigentlich hätte es diese
Beweisstücke gar nicht unbedingt
gebraucht um Simpson zum Verdächtigen zu
machen denn es gibt eine lange
Vorgeschichte von gewalttätigen
Angriffen gegen die Call die beiden o.j
und Nicole haben sich 1977 kennengelernt
1985 heirateten sie das Paar hat zwei
Kinder
1992 kommt es zur Scheidung in dieser
ganzen langen Zeit auch nach der
Scheidung leidet Nicole unter OJS
Kontrollwahn seinen Eifersucht Attacken
seinem ständigen Fremdgehen seinen
psychischen und körperlichen
Misshandlungen die so scheint es
zumindest in einem Mord ihren
schrecklichen Höhepunkt finden
am 17 Juni 1994 stellt sich OJ Simpson
nach einer ziemlich absurden
Verfolgungsjagd der Branche darüber
haben wir in der letzten Folge geredet
in Begleitung hatte er 20 Polizeiautos
und fast einem Dutzend Hubschraubern von
Fernsehsendern die das Ereignis live in
alle amerikanischen Haushalte übertragen
der Mordprozess beginnt am 9 November
1994 er wird trotz scheinbar klarer
Beweise elf Monate dauern und ich glaube
ich fange nicht an zu spoilern wenn ich
verrate mit einem Freispruch enden
von Anfang an ist es nicht nur irgendein
Prozess sondern es ist das
Medienereignis der 90er Jahre der
gesamte Prozess wird von Millionen
Zuschauern live vom Fernseher verfolgt
die Chef Anklägerin Marsha Clark ist
fest von Simpsons Schuld überzeugt zwar
gibt es keine Augenzeugen und die
Tatwaffe wurde nie gefunden doch sie
spricht von einem ocean of every Dance
einem Ozean von beweisen
sein Alibi für die genaue Tatzeit ist
schwach und unvollständig
dazu kommt die lange Geschichte von
Gewalt vor in und nach der er mit Nicole
das sind die Ideen aber Beweise die das
Blut am Tatort als eindeutig von ihm
stammen identifizieren und da ist der
blutige Handschuh den die Ermittler auf
seinem Grundstück gefunden haben die
Verteidigung wird es also sehr sehr
schwer haben Simpsons Unschuld zu
beweisen
und genau darum versucht sie es doch gar
nicht erst von Anfang an besteht ja
einziges Ziel darin Zweifel an den
Beweisen zu sehen
[Musik]
denn wie heißt es so schön im Zweifel
für den Angeklagten und genau darauf ist
ihre ganze Strategie ausgerichtet
was sagt denn die Anklage eigentlich zu
Motiv für die Tat ich meine trotz der
ganzen Vorgeschichte warum sollte oje
plötzlich hingehen und sie umbringen
die Anklage behauptet dass er Angst
gehabt habe dass ich Nicole endgültig
von dem abwenden wollte er ist ja auch
nach der Scheidung nie wirklich von ihr
losgekommen außerdem hatte es am
Nachmittag einen schlimmen Streit
zwischen den beiden um das Besuchsrecht
der Kinder gegeben vor allem aber reden
sie von einer Zündschnur die schon lange
gebrannt habe und die die Bombe eines
Tages hochgehen lassen musste der
eigentliche Anlass ist dabei fast
nebensächlich okay vielleicht ist es am
besten wenn wir uns mal nach und nach
einige der Beweise und Indizien angucken
da ist einmal das sehr wackelige Alibi
die Morde geschahen irgendwann zwischen
21 Uhr und 23:55 Uhr die Anklage geht
von 22:15 Uhr aus da um diese Uhrzeit
plötzlich Hundegebell in der Umgebung
des Tatorts zu hören war ja das muss
Nicoles Hund gewesen sein der weiße
Akita von dem wir in der letzten Folge
schon erzählt haben genau
ist 21:40 Uhr hat Simpson ein Alibi er
war mit seinem Kumpel Kate to kaylin der
in einem Gästehaus auf Simpsons
Grundstück wohnt einen Burger essen
danach sagt kaylon ihn in sein Haus
gehen
22:55 Uhr wird OJ Simpson von einer
Limousine abgeholt die ihn zum Flughafen
bringt da er am nächsten Tag einen
Termin in Chicago hat dazwischen liegen
75 Minuten in denen Simpson sich nach
eigenen Angaben vor und im Haus
aufgehalten und auf die Reise natürlich
vorbereitet hat
in diesen 75 Minuten wäre es aber ohne
weiteres möglich von Simpsons Haus zu
dem seiner Exfrau zu fahren die Morde zu
verüben und rechtzeitig für die Limo
wieder zurück zu sein denn das ist nur
eine Fahrt von 10 Minuten dennoch ist es
kein besonders großes Zeitfenster
und da setzt die Verteidigung an und
versucht Zweifel am zeitlichen Ablauf zu
wecken vor allem greifen Sie den von der
Anklage angegebenen Tatzeitpunkt von
22:15 Uhr an hätte die Tat nämlich nur
eine halbe Stunde früher oder später
stattgefunden hätte Simpsons zwischen
seinen beiden Alibis nicht genügend Zeit
gehabt die Verteidigung stürzt sich auf
eine ganze Reihe Zeugen aus der
Nachbarschaft die um 22:15 Uhr keinen
Hundegebell gehört haben eine sagte
sogar ihr sei aufgefallen dass es
außergewöhnlich still gewesen sein eine
andere erzählt dass sie gegen 22:25 Uhr
am Haus vorbei gegangen sein und weder
Hundegebell gehört noch Leichen gesehen
habe tja ist immer so eine Sache mit
Augen und Ohrenzeugen die Zeugen der
Anklage haben was gehört die der
Verteidigung nicht na toll und jetzt
mach was draus was mich aber gar nicht
wundert ist dass die eine Zeugin der
Verteidigung die Leichen nicht gesehen
hat denn das hatten wir ja schon in der
letzten Folge das Grundstück ist nicht
gut einsehbar und die Eingangstreppe an
der Nicole Brown lag ist von der
Grundstücksgrenze ein ganzes Stück
entfernt und es war dunkel die Frau hat
sicherlich auch nicht explizit nach
Leichen geguckt die ist halt einfach da
lang gelaufen
jedenfalls kann die Verteidigung den von
der Anklage präsentierten Ablauf nicht
widerlegen aber sie kann Zweifel wecken
und das ist alles was sie braucht und
was sie damit bezweckt dieser Grundsatz
im Zweifel für den Angeklagten ist gut
und richtig und ohne ihn wäre ein faires
Gerichtssystem überhaupt nicht denkbar
aber wann ist ein Zweifel ausreichend um
einen mutmaßlichen Mörder laufen zu
lassen die Anklage ist sich sicher dass
Sie alle Zweifel ausräumen wird vor
allem die DNA Beweise und der blutige
Handschuh scheint so überzeugend das
kaum ein anderer Ausgang als ein
Schuldspruch möglich scheint vielleicht
fasse ich das noch mal ganz kurz
zusammen auf dem Grundstück von Nicole
Brown Simpson wurde ein zur linken Hand
gehörender Lederhandschuh gefunden
außerdem eine Spur von blutigen
Schuhabdrücken die zum Hinterausgang des
Grundstücks führen
neben den Schuhabdrücken fand man
Tropfen von Blut die darauf hindeuten
dass sich der Täter an der linken Hand
verletzt hat am nächsten Morgen findet
man auf og Simpsons Grundstück den
passenden rechten Handschuh mit den
Blutspuren des Verdächtigen und der
Mordopfer und OJ Simpson hat eine
Schnittwunde an der linken Hand über
deren Ursprung er erst lügt und dann auf
die Erklärung ich kann mich nicht
erinnern um schwenkt als all diese
Indizien vor Gericht präsentiert werden
scheint die Sache für Simpsons gelaufen
doch alles kommt ganz anders als
Anklägerin Mascha klagt denkt die
Anklage steht den Antrag das Simpson ein
paar Handschuhe gleichen Typs und
gleicher Größe anziehen solle um zu
demonstrieren dass sie ihm passen die
Verteidigung erhebt Einspruch wenn
überhaupt dann müsste man das mit den
echten vor Ort gefundenen Handschuhen
ausprobieren ja davon hält Marshall
klagen nun überhaupt gar nichts denn
dazu müsste er zusätzliche
Latexhandschuhe tragen um das
Beweisstück nicht zu verunreinigen aber
Richter genehmigt die Demonstration
damit kommt es zur ikonischen Szene des
ganzen Prozesses
OJ Simpson kann sich nur unter aller
größten Mühen die Handschuhe vom Tatort
anziehen sie sind im eindeutig zu klein
und dieses Szene ist viel überzeugender
als alles was davor und danach vor
Gericht präsentiert wird vor allem die
DNA Beweise können es nicht mit dieser
greifbaren Demonstration aufnehmen das
waren halt irgendwelche trockenen
Expertenaussagen vor einer Jury die
nicht aus Experten sondern aus zufällig
ausgewählten Bürgern bestand den
Analysen waren damals auch noch ein
recht neues Werkzeug der Forensik und es
gab viele Zweifel an dieser angeblich
neuen Wunderwaffe die niemand richtig
verstanden und dem gegenüber der
selbstsicher lächelnde Angeklagte der
vor den Augen der ganzen Welt
demonstriert dass ihm der Handschuh
nicht passt
das war einfach der Wendepunkt von
diesem Schlag wird sich die Anklage nie
wieder erholen ja und die ganze
handschuhgeschichte die wird ja noch
schlimmer sie wird sich zu einem totalen
Albtraum für Marshall Clark entwickelt
aber erstmal Mirko wenn der Handschuh
offensichtlich nicht passt dann
tja dann heißt es eigentlich erstmal gar
nichts denn da sind ja noch die
Latexhandschuhe die Simpson tragen
musste um den Handschuh das Beweisstück
nicht zu kontaminieren vor allem aber
sagt ein Vertreter des Herstellers aus
dass die Handschuhe schrumpfen könnten
wenn sie sich etwas mit Flüssigkeit zum
Beispiel blutvoll sorgen das klingt für
mich ziemlich einleuchtend die Anklage
lässt oje daraufhin einen Fabrik neues
Paar derselben Marke und derselben
größer anprobieren
und es passt problemlos
aber all das spielt bald keine Rolle
mehr als ein anderes Thema in den
Mittelpunkt der Verhandlungen rückt aber
noch eine Sache zu den nicht passenden
Handschuhen viele Jahre nach dem Prozess
kommt heraus dass Simpsons zum
Tatzeitpunkt und darüber hinaus
Arthritis Medikamente nahm zwei Wochen
vor der handschuh-show vor Gericht hat
er diese abgesetzt was vermutlich dazu
geführt hat dass seine Hände
angeschwollen sind als Reaktion auf das
Absetzen der Medikamente quasi
1995 wusste niemand von den Medikamenten
wahrscheinlich nicht einmal das
Verteidiger Team
aber jetzt kommen wir zu einem Mann der
maßgeblich dazu beiträgt dass der
Prozess gegen o.j Simpson mit einem
Freispruch endet dieser Mann ist der
letzte der sich einen Freispruch für OJ
Simpson gewünscht hätte Mark Forman
vielleicht erinnert ihr euch noch an
Mark Formen der Detective ist bereits in
den ersten beiden Folgen aufgetaucht
1985 war er es der wegen des Verdachts
auf häusliche Gewalt zum Haus der
Simpsons gerufen wurde und am Morgen
nach der Tat war er es der über den Zaun
von ogis Anwesen geklettert war und der
dort den blutigen Handschuh gefunden
hatte Mark Formen ist eine der
wichtigsten Zeugen der Anklage
und Mark Formen ist Rassist und zwar so
richtig richtig hardcore das stellt sich
im Prozessverlauf raus also das war
jemand der hat Sachen gesagt die ich
wirklich nicht wiederholen möchte
für die Verteidigung ist firmend damit
natürlich ein gefundenes Fressen erst
recht nachdem er unter Eid rassistische
Äußerungen bestreitet und dann der Lüge
überführt wird dieser Zeuge hat jede
Glaubwürdigkeit verloren und die
Verteidiger gehen noch ein Schritt
weiter und behaupten Firmen habe den
Handschuh am Tatort mitgehen lassen und
dann selber auf Simpsons Grundstück
platziert das würde zwar immer noch
nicht die Blutspuren von Simpson und den
Opfern am Handschuh erklären und erst
recht nicht weitere Blutspuren die unter
anderem am Türgriff von Simpsons Wagen
gefunden wurden und überhaupt also die
Verteidigung die hat keinerlei Beweise
für ihre Behauptung aber diese Beweise
brauchte es nicht denn es reicht bei der
Jury Zweifel zu sehen Ihnen den Gedanken
aber könnte es nicht vielleicht so
gewesen sein einzupflanzen ja und das
gelingt zumal dieser Prozess sowieso
schon mit solchen Fragen aufgeladen ist
früher war OJ Simpson der schwarze
Superstar den fast alle mochten ja sogar
Mark Forman der Rassist der hat ihn
bewundert
doch das alles kippt während des
Prozesses und viele Medien beginnen
regelrecht gegen ihn zu hetzen eines der
übelsten Beispiele dafür ist die
Zeitschrift time die zeigt ein Porträt
von Simpson auf der Titelseite bei dem
sie seine Haut massiv nachgedunkelt hat
weil ihnen der Original o.j zu
hellhäutig war Firmen wird vom
Hauptbelastungszeugen zum wichtigsten
Argument der Verteidigung am 3 oktober
1995 verkündet die 12-köpfige Jury vor
150 Millionen live fernsehzuschauen ihr
werdet und entlastet Simpson in beiden
Fällen des Smartphones
OJ Simpson wird umgehend aus der Haft
entlassen
interessant ist aber z.B das unbekannt
ist wie die Line Jury zu ihrem Ergebnis
gekommen ist also so eine Jury die kann
in den Vereinigten Staaten aus zwei
Gründen einen Angeklagten freisprechen
einmal weil sie Zweifel an der Schuld
hat oder einfach so das klingt jetzt
komisch für uns aber ja so eine Jury
kann entgegen der Beweise und der
geltenden Gesetze freisprechen und so
ein Freispruch der ist dann halt
rechtskräftig und endgültig
und wichtig ist auch noch zu erwähnen
dass die Staatsanwaltschaft nach so
einem Urteil nicht in Berufung gehen
kann
also kann OJ Simpson nie wieder vor
einem Strafgericht für diesen Mord
angeklagt werden selbst wenn er ihn im
Nachhinein gestehen sollte
ja aber er wird noch einmal für diesen
Mord angeklagt allerdings diesmal vor
einem Zivilgericht von dem es nicht um
eine Haftstrafe sondern um
Schadensersatz geht
ein Jahr nach dem Freispruch strengen
die Hinterbliebenen einen solchen
Prozess an und OJ Simpson wird für
schuldig befunden und zur Zahlung von
33,5 Millionen Dollar an die
Opferfamilien verurteilt ein Großteil
seines Vermögens steckt aber in
Immobilien die er selbst nutzt und
zusätzlich noch in einem pensionsform
beides ist gegen Pfändung geschützt also
letztlich zahlt Simpson ungefähr eine
halbe Million Dollar und kann sein
eigenes Luxusleben einfach weiterführen
bis er 2008 dann doch noch ins Gefängnis
kommt aber für eine ganz andere tat
denn am 13 September 2007 hat OJ Simpson
mit Komplizen einen Sammler von
Fanartikeln überfallen und zur
Herausgabe von Erinnerungsstücken
gezwungen die dieser angeblich von ihm
gestohlen hat
ein Gericht verurteilt ihn daraufhin
zumindestens neun und maximal 33 Jahren
Haft für bewaffneten Raub und
Geiselnahme
2017 wird OJ Simpson aus der Haft
entlassen
2021 endet auch seine Bewährungszeit
OJ Simpson lebt als freier Mann in Las
Vegas vielleicht lassen wir das letzte
Wort Kim Goldman das ist die Schwester
von Ronald Goldman der zusammen mit
Nicole Brown ermordet wurde
ich höre er genießt das süße Leben in
Las Vegas wo er wie ein König behandelt
wird ich ersticke nicht in meiner Trauer
aber jeder Meilenstein den meine Kinder
oder ich erreichen der erinnert mich
daran was ich alles nicht mehr mit
meinem Bruder teilen kann und daran was
ihm verwehrt bleibt
und damit sind wir am Ende unseres
Dreiteilers über den Mordprozess gegen
OJ Simpson
vielen Dank dass ihr dabei wart für
diese Serie haben wir uns mit vielen
Artikeln beschäftigt unter anderem von
die Welt NTV Business Insider baltimor
Sun und Gala aber die beste Quelle auch
die wollen wir euch nicht vorenthalten
die war ein anderer Podcast ja der
amerikanische Podcast your long about
der hat eine eigene Miniserie zu diesem
Fall also nicht ganz so mini das sind
ungefähr ein Dutzend Folgen von jeweils
über einer Stunde aber klar da gibt's
halt richtig viele Details und man kann
sich auch die eigenen Geschichten z.B
die von Nicole Brown noch viel viel
tiefer reinfuchsen also wer da Lust
drauf hat den kann ich euch wirklich nur
empfehlen also für alle die es
interessiert der Podcast heißt
wir verlinken euch den aber auch
ansonsten gerne noch mal bei insta also
schreibt uns an wenn ihr da fragen habt
wie ihr uns sonst noch erreicht findet
ihr natürlich wie immer in den Show
Notes wir sagen adios für heute danke
dass ihr diesmal wieder mit dabei war
und ich hoffe wir hören uns auch nächste
Woche wieder und natürlich auch vielen
Dank von mir und gern bis zum nächsten
mal euer Mirko und eure tun